A living building
is really a building
that is a positive contributor
to its broader ecology
throughout every stage
of its life.
So conventional buildings
are responsible for
about 37% of global
greenhouse gas emissions.
And given the fact that we spend
about 90% of our time in them,
they tend to off-gas
a ton of harmful chemicals
into our indoor air
and also contribute to a growing
pollution and waste problem.
A living building
takes responsibility in account
for everything
that comes into its DNA
and all of the effluents that
flow out into its environment.
It's really exciting
to have the living village here
on campus at Yale
because it opens up
an opportunity
for us to get to understand
and learn
about our local climate,
our flora, our fauna,
and in doing so, engage
and prototype new ways
of living together.